so on the 8th of April 2014 a security
advisory was released on the internet by
people at Google and other places that
they discovered a bug in a package
called open SSL one problem with the
package like open SSL is that being so
pervasive if a book does get into it
then it'll filter out on to lots and
lots of machines so to understand this
heartbleed bug we actually need to
understand in detail how the heartbeat
protocol works so let's move into the
office and actually understand how part
beat works like all internet protocols
these are defined in the request for
comments or RFC s and if you look down
here there'll be a link to where you can
download this one and you can go from
there to find anyone there's a heartbeat
request which we send out and there's a
heartbeat response which comes back from
the other side the made up of three or
four things we've got this type field
and this can either be a value of 1
which means request a heartbeat or a
value of 2 which means I'm sending a
response to request that you've actually
sent we then have this payload and this
can be anything the person requesting
the heartbeat likes it's just some
unique value it doesn't even have to be
unique but it helps if it is that they
send to the server and the server when
it responds sends back exactly the same
response there finally we have what's
called some padding and this is at least
16 bytes a random data which just bulks
out the actual message that's sent it's
ignored by the other side but it's there
as part of the protocol what this means
though is that even though we know how
big the messages we don't know how big
the payload is unless we actually send
over the length of it because we don't
know how long the padding is either so
we also send over before we send the
payload two bytes which gives us the
payload length which means a payload can
be anything up to 65536 bytes in length
and that will get sent as part of the
request and the service job is to copy
that payload create a response message
around it and send it back to me to tell
me that it's met that response and if we
just look down here at the bottom it
says if the payload length of a received
Harbury message is
to large the received heartbeat message
must be discarded silently what that
means is if I send you a message where
the payload length doesn't make sense
for example it's greater than the actual
length of the message then the server is
meant to ignore that message completely
not trying presses it and send a
response because it doesn't make sense
and it's that handling of that situation
that causes the heartbleed bug in open
SSL open SSL is written in C as we're
gonna look at the code here but I'll
walk you through it so if you're not
familiar with the C language we should
be able to follow it without any issues
so I've opened a profile here called a
t1 lib which is the file that contains
implementation of the heartbeat
extension if we scroll right down to the
bottom of the file we find that there
are a couple of functions that implement
the heartbeat protocol first of all I'm
going to look at is this one called TLS
one underscore heartbeat which is
actually responsible for sending the
messages out over the connection it does
some checking to check there's no
heartbeat already being sent and then we
come to this bit of code which actually
generates the message there's no problem
with this code it's generating the
message in a way that makes sense it's
allocating memory here of the right
length it's putting in the relevant
bytes is saying it's a request message
this is how big the pay that is it's 18
bytes long it's generating the payload
and it's sending its random padding
bytes out over and then we can see here
it calls SSL 3 right bytes to send that
out over the net covert connection to
the other side so that's all fine that
doesn't seem to be any problems with
that but if we scroll up a bit we come
to the code which processes the
heartbeat and that's in the function
called TLS one process heartbeat and
what this does it gets sent a message
that's been received from the other side
and it starts pressing that to see
whether it's a valid heartbeat request
and if it is it will generate the
response to the other side so it reads
in from the package the heartbeat type
and it also extracts out the payload
length from there now one of the things
you have to do when dealing with Network
protocols is that there is defined
method for how data is sent over the
network and that is what's called a big
Indian Way of transmitting things PC
computers tend to be little-endian and
so on and so you sometimes have to
convert between it so only have this
function network too short here which
does that conversion for us so we get
the length of the payload there's then
some more code which just some tests and
then we say if we've got a heartbeat
request message we're going to process
that and so it's going to generate the
response so the first thing it does is
it allocates memory before the response
message and so that's one byte for the
type in this case it's a heartbeat
response two bytes for the length of the
payload then however many Bart is
required for the payload remember it's
read that from the actual packet that's
come in and it then creates its padding
in this case it's going to generate
sixteen bytes again so allocates that
memory in assuming that gets allocated
properly it starts to fill in those
details so it's saying here that I want
a response message and so it says that's
the type and it sets the payload in
there again and again he's having to
convert it from the computer's type into
the network type so it's in the
standardized format and so he's putting
payload bytes in there so that's the
value it read in and then it uses this
function here mem copy which just copies
a block of memory from one location to
another to copy
payload number of bytes from the
original message which had the payload
in it it then adds the padding and sends
the data out over the network well
what's the problem with that that code
works and it works fine providing the
packets at a cent or standard the
problem comes the heartbleed bug as it
is comes if the packet that we send
isn't standard is is crafted maliciously
and in particular the key problem is
this payload length that we use to copy
the bytes from one memory location to
another we read that in from the packet
that we sent and so if we create a
packet that has a payload say of 64 K
65,536 bytes would only actually provide
say 8 bytes of data when it starts to
copy
is going to copy those 8 bytes of data
but this mem copy instruction here is
going to carry on copying for another 60
5528 worth of bytes now where those
extra bytes going to come from well
they're going to come from whatever
follows on in memory in the computer's
memory that's there if we're lucky that
data will be meaningless
it'll be garbage that's been left in
there it doesn't make any sense but it
could also be details of previous
requests usernames passwords and if
we're really unlucky it could be the
actual security certificates used to
actually encrypt the data fixing this
was really easy they just added checks
and like it described in the RFC that
the payload length made sense in the
context of the length of the actual
message but let's actually see what
happens if we take a server that's still
got the old version and see what data we
can collect if we run this heartbleed
bug they've set up a virtual machine
running OpenBSD using a version that
still got the heartbleed booked so if I
open a new web window here I can pop to
the web server this is really not on the
local machine and if I switch now to my
command line I've also got a piece of
code that I downloaded off the web and
no we're not going to give you a link to
this one that will actually exploit your
heartbleed and slurp 64k of data from
that server and will be able to look at
it in the window here it's written in
Python and we're going to attack the
server that we've got here don't worry
this is a local IP you won't be able to
connect to it and if we just run that we
can see the data that we've got now the
data that we get back is completely
random it depends where when the server
received that message you put it in same
computer's memory so in this case we've
not got anything interesting but if we
run it again so this time when we run it
it's actually giving us some useful
information so what have we got here
well at the top we've got some details
about what's going on it's telling us it
is connected to the server that it sent
some data oh it's something hello
message and so on which is setting up
the TLS and if it sent the heartbeat
request and it's received our response
now this horribly mystical request has
been formatted in a way that it's sent a
very small amount of data but asked
for a large amount of data or said it's
a large amount of data so what gets sent
back is about 64 Kay's worth of memory
it's then dumped this memory out to the
screen so we can see what's going on so
on the left hand column here we've got
its position within the data to return
so we start off at 0 and we're
increasing in hexadecimal down here so
we've got 16 32 48 and so on all in
hexadecimal down here up to 256 along
here we have the hexadecimal values of
each of those bytes and on the
right-hand side the ASCII values of them
what those characters actually mean so
in this bit we've got part of our Hobby
response at the top but as we look down
we've actually started to get some
interesting information out of the
server in this case we can see what the
referring URL was what encoding is
accepted and we can start to see earlier
things that I've been doing when I was
testing this so I started to set up
WordPress so we can see that someone
tried to access that so it's a bit like
panning for gold we stick our
metaphorical sieve into the mud and we
pull out things and we're shaking it
around occasionally or we pull out is
much just random data we can't decipher
but occasionally pull out and we start
together and we get those gold nuggets
so we're interested in we get the
passwords we get the services to
Ferguson's own which we can use to do
nefarious things if we were so inclined
now of course you wouldn't necessarily
want to do this by hand but it'd be very
easy to write software that could look
for these patterns and just sit there
continually fetching data undetected
until it found what it was looking for
and everybody was going to click on that
one what turned out that the video
behind that was a person talking about
that fight